with the White Queen Checkmate  Unstoppable almost but uh yeah at the  moment the black started retreating it  went wrong  this is a good move no yeah and now you  can take the bishop minimum but can you  take the Knight here quite possibly yeah  this is the simplest way to  uh just get your material back I say  well you know and uh still attack  ING with everything here so yeah this  this is it's going to be a very  interesting final yeah right I mean  Arjun versus uh young young versus old  can we call Magnus old I don't know I  guess so yeah well against the 19 year  olds and here it is we have a teenager  in the final and the Julia's very  generation cup he knocks out Liam one of  the top players this season on the tour  we could actually see some reaction from  the Indian Ice Man there he looked a  little bit relieved and very happy look  at this what do you think Ivanka it  means for Arjun to now being a final to  face the world